[Musique]
bonjour Mélanie Vogel bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre première invitée
de la saison dis-nous durée ce nouveau
plateau ce nouveau décor on est ravi de
vous recevoir vous êtes sénatrice
écologiste pour présenter les Français
établis hors de France on va voir
l'actualité avec vous et on commence
évidemment parce qu'il s'est passé ce
week-end au Maroc plus de 2000 morts
dans ce terrible séisme Emmanuel Macron
dit que la France est prête à aider le
Maroc quand il le jugera utile mais le
Maroc te demande toujours pas l'aide de
la France est la solliciter l'aide de
quatre pays mais pas le nôtre est-ce que
vous déplorez le fait que Mohammed VI ne
demande pas l'aide de la France
d'abord si vous me le permettez exprimer
parce que je crois que c'est le plus
important aujourd'hui ma plus grande
solidarité avec avec le Maroc avec les
Marocains et avec toutes les personnes
qui vivent au Maroc qui subissent les
conséquences de ce séisme avec aussi des
personnes en France qui ont des proches
et qui sont endeuillés ou inquiets
puisque le bilan d'enfou vous faites
état et sans doute pas définitif et que
des opérations de recherche et de
sauvetage sont encore en cours moi je
crois que ma place aujourd'hui c'est pas
de rentrer dans la discussion je dirais
diplomatique entre les deux pays s'il y
a un travail diplomatique à faire pour
que l'aide de la France puisse être
acheminés vers le Maroc que les
personnes compétentes le fassent et
j'espère en tout cas la France tient
prête à faire ce qu'il faut et j'espère
que les conditions sont réunies pour que
s'il aide est nécessaire et juger
nécessaire elle puisse être apportée
est-ce que à votre échelle vous allez
prendre une initiative est-ce que Europe
Écologie Les Verts va prendre une
initiative pour aider les populations
sinistrées oui moi en tant que sénatrice
des Françaises et des Français de
l'étranger j'ai prévu de d'appeler les
nos compatriotes à l'étranger à être
solidaires avec le Maroc il y a
plusieurs ONG françaises et
internationales qui récoltent des dons
pour qu'on puisse venir en secours à la
population et puis réparer parce que un
séisme pareil il s'agit pas de venir en
aide sur le court terme ça prend des
années on voit en Turquie le temps que
ça prend pour pouvoir se relever donc
oui évidemment nous sommes nous sommes
solidaires et nous allons chacun et
beaucoup de personnes ailleurs en France
franco-marocaine notamment ont pris
publiquement des initiatives en ce sens
l'autre actualité de cette rentrée c'est
encore et toujours l'inflation la hausse
des prix préoccupe les Français
notamment la hausse des prix à la pompe
est-ce qu'il faut que l'État aide les
Français à faire face à la hausse des
prix des carburants mais évidemment si
vous voulez on est dans une dans une
situation où depuis le début de la crise
inflationniste le gouvernement fait
comme si l'inflation c'était quelque
chose qui arrivait un que du ciel et
contre lequel on ne pouvait rien
ça fait depuis 2017 que Bruno demande je
pense qu'effectivement il serait temps
2023 que Bruno fasse il Bruno Le Maire
face et parce que nous savons que en
fait l'inflation ce n'est pas une
fatalité et des explications à
l'inflation la Banque centrale
européenne et le FMI donc on peut pas
dire que ce sont des repères de
gauchistes nous disent que la plus
grande explication de l'inflation
aujourd'hui ce sont les marges et les
profits des grandes entreprises et ça on
peut faire quelque chose on peut réguler
l'actionnariat on peut augmenter le SMIC
on peut augmenter le point d'indice on
peut prendre des mesures de régulation
des prix on peut prendre des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat comme la sécurité
sociale de l'alimentation comme le
chèque énergie etc donc il y a beaucoup
sur l'aide au carburant là aussi il faut
que les aides pour les Français écoutez
sur le court terme
évidemment qu'il faut pouvoir
l'énergie c'est le poste le plus
important impacté par l'inflation
d'accord c'est l'énergie et
l'alimentation et ce sont des besoins
vitaux ce sont des besoins essentiels
donc évidemment qu'il faut pouvoir aider
les Français à avoir accès à l'énergie
mais il dit que c'est contradictoires de
parler de réchauffement climatique et
d'aider les de subventionner les
énergies fossiles vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ça et je suis d'accord sur
le long terme évidemment évidemment je
veux dire pour moi on serait pas dans
cette situation si le programme des
écologistes si vous voulez avait été
appliquée il y a de très nombreuses
années et qu'on ne soit plus dans une
situation de dépendance au pétrole
aujourd'hui malheureusement on n'a pas
fait la transition énergétique on a mis
les Françaises et les Français dans une
situation de dépendance aux énergies
fossiles donc il faut évidemment pouvoir
répondre à la question du pouvoir
d'achat mais ça doit être couplé et
c'est indispensable un plan sérieux
crédible chiffré et financé de
transition écologique qui permettent de
sortir de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles d'arriver à une France et une
Europe 100% renouvelable et de faire que
les Françaises et les Français et les
altern à la voiture à l'électricité et
qui puisse finalement sur le court terme
une sur le côté terminé sur le court
terme une aide qui peut prendre
différentes formes d'ailleurs Emmanuel
Macron qui a donné jusqu'à hier soir au
parti politique pour répondre à sa
lettre suite à la rencontre de
Saint-Denis repécologie écologie les
verres a publié sa lettre hier soir ça
veut dire vous continuez le processus
les verres se rendront la prochaine
rencontre écoutez ça dépend de des
réponses qui vont nous être faites et de
ce qui va sortir de tout ce processus
moi vous savez on nous appelle pour
dîner et discuter de la vie et des
problèmes du pays on y va il n'y a pas
de problème mais on est quand même dans
une situation où on a un gouvernement et
vous recevez cela ne cesse Guérini tout
à l'heure qui nous explique que on est
rentré dans l'histoire avec un processus
démocratique inédit parce que les
responsable politique se sont rencontré
une soirée pour discuter des problèmes
du pays pour moi ça montre quand même en
creux le dysfonctionnement nous
institutions démocratiques qui
républicaines qui existent le Parlement
voilà les syndicats on est là on n'est
pas besoin de se voir pendant 12 heures
à huis clos avec des brouilleurs
interdiction du téléphone pour discuter
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez pour
discuter de choses dont on discute tous
les jours ici à la télé au Parlement etc
donc nous en tout cas le déplorer la
méthode mais vous continuez quand même
le processus la méthode elle est elle
est symptomatique le fait qu'on
considère que c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire que des gens se soient
vus pour parler des problèmes du pays
c'est un peu inquiétant mais sur le fond
parce que c'est quand même ça le plus
important nous avons trois inquiétudes
majeures premièrement ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises mais je le répète ici
on a quasiment pas parlé d'écologie à ce
stade nous avons été les seuls à ramener
et ramener ce sujet sur la table or
c'est le problème de l'humanité
aujourd'hui et c'est l'essentiel de
votre lettre il y a une feuille il y a
une feuille de route de la transition
écologique qui doit être présentée dans
les prochains jours qu'est-ce que vous
en attendez j'en attends que la France
prenne toute sa part à conduire le pays
et le continent vers une Europe nette
carbone en 2040 vers une Europe de la
transition écologique totale la deuxième
chose il y avait trois points pardon non
l'écologie était absente c'est
extrêmement inquiétant juste pour finir
sur l'écologie après on va revenir sur
deux points mais Emmanuel Macron hier et
il était au sommet du G20 il a jugé
insuffisante les résultats de ce sommet
en matière de climat il a alerté tout le
monde je le cite sur la nécessité de
fixer des objectifs plus ambitieux
notamment sur la sortie du pétrole
est-ce que c'est la preuve qu'il n'est
pas si anti-écolo que vous le dites non
mais moi en fait je commence à ne pas
être de moins en moins intéressé si vous
voulez à ce qui est manuel Macron dit
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qu'on
fait d'accord ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
en tant que Français au niveau européen
c'est réclamé une pause environnementale
donc il peut aller au G20 expliquer que
ce serait bien de faire plus mais en
tout cas ici il est en train d'expliquer
qu'il faudrait faire un peu moins ce qui
est quand même extrêmement
contradictoire donc il faut pas qu'il y
ait de nouvelles normes c'est ce qu'il
avait demandé avant l'été oui mais en
fait moi je sais pas comment on fait
pour pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone si on n'a pas de nouvelles
normes à part une opération magique dont
je n'ai pas le secret je ne sais pas
comment on fait on est obligé d'avoir
une transition écologique elle n'est pas
finie donc il faut continuer à réguler
la deuxième chose qui est inquiétante
dans ses rencontres c'est le fait qu'il
y a un refus total du gouvernement
d'adresser la question qui est la
question sociale majeure actuellement
qui est de revenir sur le débat de la
réforme des retraites on entre on a une
crise sociale démocratique qui a émergé
de cela et on entre dans une discussion
en disant alors ça on va pas en parler
c'est quand même problématique et dans
votre lettre vous demandez un référendum
d'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
j'ai pas tourné pour vous non la page
est pas tournée et je vois pas comment
la tourner autrement que en revenant
démocratiquement envers les citoyens sur
cette question qui a été la question des
mois qui viennent de s'écouler et on est
là et on est le 11 septembre la réforme
est entrée en vigueur il y a quelques
jours et c'est une réforme je je répète
qui était refusé par 90% des actifs 70%
des Français et le Parlement on a un
problème on peut pas en fait passer
juste au dessus comme ça la troisième
chose c'est que je pense que tout cela
démontre majoritairement un problème
institutionnel démocratique en France et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
poussons pour un véritable travail
constituant pour sortir la 5ème
République et rentrer dans une phase au
fond j'ai envie de dire démocratique
normal ou en fait ce genre de débat se
passe de façon normale au Parlement vous
savez dans cette émission on regarde
l'actualité à travers ma région grâce à
la presse régionale on va parler de la
question des bassines pour ça on va
aller à Poitiers retrouvez Baptiste bise
bonjour Baptiste merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur adjoint de la
Nouvelle République et de s'entreprises
dans la Vienne Baptiste vous nous parlez
ce matin de ce procédé militants
antibacine qui s'est tenu à Niort
vendredi dernier
d'abord parce que c'est un sujet qui
intéresse particulièrement votre invité
mais aussi parce que ce procès était
vraiment hors norme à tel point que
l'audience n'a pas pu à la son terme
vendredi faute de temps alors je
rappelle que 9 militants Antibi pour
avoir organisé les manifestations des
pannes dans les Deux-Sèvres en mars 2022
puis sainte Soline 1 en octobre et
sainte-soling 2 dont on a beaucoup parlé
dans les médias nationaux le 23 mars
dernier humblement qui avait donné lieu
à des dégradations sur des canalisations
d'irrigation et surtout à de violences
affrontements avec de l'ordre alors
parmi ces prévenus accusés d'avoir
organisé ces manifestations interdites
on retrouve responsable de la
Confédération paysanne de solidaire de
la CGT mais aussi des porte-paroles du
collectif non merci et les soulèvements
de la terre
leurs avocats ont tenté de faire annuler
la procédure en expliquant que le
parquet n'avait avancé aucun élément
concret pour étayer son accusation les
prévenus ont tous pris la parole
spontanément et ils ont tous indiqué au
président du tribunal qu'il ferait
ensuite valoir leur droit au silence
l'audience a donc suspendu dans la
soirée de vendredi elle ne reprendra que
le 28 novembre prochain les militants
antibacilles avaient prévenu qu'il
voulait faire de leur procès une tribune
politique on peut vraiment dire qu'ils
ont atteint leur objectif près de 3
manifestants étaient rassemblés dans la
paisible préfecture des Deux-Sèvres
vendredi de nombreux responsables
politiques qui étaient également là donc
la secrétaire nationale des Verts et
l'événement était largement couvert par
les médias nationaux
et Baptiste tous les manifestants ne
sont pas rentrés chez eux vendredi soir
c'est ça plusieurs viennent d'entre eux
se sont retrouvés à proximité du
chantier de la bassine en construction à
prière toujours dans le Poitou samedi en
plus de toutes les réserves de
substitution déjà existantes et
financées sans être public il s'agit de
la transit bassine du projet contesté
qui est porté par la coopérative de
l'eau des Deux-Sèvres la manifestation
s'est déroulée dans le hall les
militants ont érigés un barrage en bois
en travers de la route avant de faire le
tour du chantier ils ont fait tomber les
grilles un avertissement selon bassine
non merci qui a publié un communiqué
pour revendiquer l'action et puis qui
annoncent des actions de son côté la
préfecture a condamné la destruction de
plusieurs barrières à prière et
l'intérieur de compteur d'eau à Mauzé
sur le mignon ou une bassine est déjà en
service dans le département voisin de
l'Est où je me trouve à Poitiers une
trentaine de bassines doivent être
construites dans le seul bassin du Clain
et le préfet estimé la semaine dernière
que le moratoire exigé par les opposants
était en réalité un ultimatum sous la
menace d'action vivante
il a une phrase forte pour pour évoquer
cette situation il a dit on ne dialogue
pas avec un flingue posé sur la table
d'où ma question madame la sénatrice
jugez-vous les violences et dégradations
légitimes et nécessaires pour manifester
l'opposition au bassines
alors tout d'abord un mot sur ce procès
on est en train de faire aujourd'hui le
procès au fond de la désobéissance
civile du syndicalisme de l'action
politique de l'engagement écologiste
alors qu'on devrait dans cette affaire
faire au moins autant le procès du
projet de l'agro-industrie et au fond
des projets climaticides
moi et l'ensemble des écologistes nous
sommes et nous le répétons à longueur de
journée à chaque fois qu'on nous le
demande pour la non-violence etc mais
enfin on a une situation où qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on fasse tous les
recours ne sont pas terminés j'ai la
conviction comme ça a été le cas pour le
barrage de silence qu'à la fin ce projet
n'est pas légal j'en suis convaincue je
suis convaincue que vis-à-vis des normes
qui sont en place à la fois au niveau
national et européen ce projet n'est pas
légal
on a une situation où malgré tout on
persiste dans un projet je le rappelle
parce que les manifestants les
manifestants les opposants les opposants
au projet ils font pas ça par plaisir
ils aimeraient bien faire autre chose de
leur week-end mais le problème qu'on a
c'est qu'on est dans un dans une
situation où la crise de l'eau elle est
pas fictive elle est là on a des
restrictions d'eau tous les étés on a
des villages qui sont approvisionnés
avec des citernes en France aujourd'hui
on a des pays dans le monde on demande
aux gens de boire de l'eau salée parce
qu'il y a plus d'eau potable disponibles
et là on a un projet qui consiste à
aller pomper de l'eau dans les nappes
phréatiques
qui sont vides qui se vident pour aller
les réutiliser l'été pour des projets de
l'agro-industrie qui ne sont pas
durables c'est une folie alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait moi
j'aimerais bien que par la sagesse par
le respect justement de l'État de droit
de l'intérêt général et bien on arrête
ce projet c'est quoi votre proposition
alternative sérieusement c'est quoi
on est l'action politique elle se
déroule dans un contexte si le contexte
vous empêche simplement avec des
amendements avec des prises de parole
comme ici ce matin de faire reculer un
projet qui va à l'encontre de l'intérêt
général à un moment qu'est-ce que vous
faites oui la désobéissance civile fait
partie des modes d'action pacifistes qui
fonctionnent à 6 vins il se trouve que
et j'espère qu'on va pas attendre comme
à Sylvain skier à mort on a arrêté le
projet et on s'est aperçu après qu'il
était illégal elle parlait vous parler
de la désobéissance civil lyrique
dupond-moretty la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée a dit qu'il en avait
ras-le-bol il a exprimé son ras-le-bol
face à la petite musique je le cite de
la désobéissance civile mise en oeuvre
par l'extrême gauche que lui
répondez-vous mais moi j'en ai
ras-le-bol d'avoir un gouvernement qui
promet des projets climaticites qui vont
à l'encontre de l'intérêt général vous
savez dans une société il y a un contrat
social qui est quand même fondé sur le
fait que les personnes qui sont
responsabilité publique agissent en
fonction du bien commun
si ce contrat est brisé à un moment
donné on a un problème et la
désobéissance elle est civile elle est
là pour ça c'est un moyen d'action qui
est qui marche qui marche les luttes
féministes les luttes sociales les
luttes environnementales elles ont été
parfois remportées grâce à la
désobéissance civile et on en a besoin
d'un désobéissance civile quand on a des
gouvernants qui vont à l'encontre de
l'intérêt général et quand on a des lois
qui sont en fait à l'encontre du bien
commun si on avait passé loi si on
n'avait pas ces projets absurdes on
n'aurait pas besoin de la désobéissance
civile et encore une fois on fait pas ça
pour nous moi j'ai autre chose à faire
de mes weekends j'aimerais bien qu'on
parle d'autre chose j'en ai marre de
parler des bassines j'en ai marre c'est
vrai mais voilà on fait ça parce que
c'est le seul moyen de parvenir à un
pays qui
une économie de société qui respecte les
lignes planétaires on est quand même
voilà on peut pas faire autrement que de
respecter limite planétaire on va
remercier Baptiste merci beaucoup
Baptiste d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde vos deux une oui allez-y
juste une précision si vous m'entendez
c'est la crise que tous ces projets
étaient légaux la plupart des voix de
recours ont été épuisés pour la plupart
des projets dans la Vienne toutes les
voix cours ont été épuisées et plusieurs
dizaines de bassines ont déjà été
construites avec l'autorisation de la
justice en charente-marie donc on peut
pas dire que tous les projets soient
illégaux il y a des projets c'est ça
c'est le principe de la désobéissance et
il y a des projets légaux qui sont
illégitimes parce qu'ils mettent en
péril notre vie sur Terre
oui ben désobéit civilement Baptiste
vaune la Une de La Nouvelle République
covid-19 où en est-on dans la Vienne et
la Une de s'entreprises vous revenez sur
ce séisme au Maroc une poitevine raconte
c'est à la une de vos deux journaux
merci beaucoup merci Baptiste d'avoir
été avec nous on vous retrouve
évidemment très vite dans cette émission
on va maintenant accueillir Quentin on
va parler de votre partie mais la niveau
gel vous avez fait beaucoup parler de
vous cet été alors que sous la campagne
des européennes les écologistes
n'ont-ils pas raté leur rentrée vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez d'abord
on fait le point avec Quentin calmer
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Mélanie Vogel bonjour Quentin pour cette
rentrée vous allez nous parler d'une
contrepèformance c'est la question
contre-performance pour le parti
europécologie les Verts les chiffres des
dernières enquêtes d'opinion semblent en
berne pour les écologistes
de l'Ifop ne sont pas très bons on va
aller un garder mais les niveaux gel
votre partie était crédité fin août et
bien de 8% d'attention de vote aux
élections européennes à la liste menée
par votre candidate Marie Toussaint des
chiffres à 8% qui sont en plus en berne
même par rapport à la précédente enquête
que vous voyez juste en dessous puisque
et bien c'est l'intention de vote était
à 10% en juin dernier c'est donc ces
chiffres qui interrogent sur la
stratégie sur le positionnement
politique de votre partie le dérèglement
climatique était au cœur de l'actualité
cet été Europe Écologie Les Verts ne
semble pas en avoir profité c'est
effectivement ce qu'on aurait pu penser
mais les nouveaux gel vous aviez un
boulevard face à l'accumulation
effectivement des informations cet été
sur le réchauffement climatique on en
parlait il y a un instant à propos des
belles sites mais entre la sécheresse et
aussi les épisodes de canicule en France
et bien on s'est dit qu'on aurait pu
parler beaucoup de dérèglements
climatique mais votre partie c'est
illustré par des polémiques en août vous
voyez par exemple elle est titres sur
l'invitation adressée au rappeur made in
lors de vos universités d'été ce rappeur
qui en plus venait encore de poster un
message ambigu sur les réseaux sociaux à
propos de la police de la politique
Rachel Kahn et à propos même de cette
polémique là votre ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle a reconnu que
vous aviez prêté le flanc à ceux qui
voientissent regardez ce qu'a dit Noël
mammaire sur France Inter alors où tout
ce que nous disions depuis près de 40
ans et vérifier valider par les
scientifiques ou la crise écologique est
devenue une véritable menace
existentielle pour l'humanité c'est très
ennuyeux enfin dernière séquence Mélanie
Vogel celle sur l'interdiction des
abayas dans les collèges et dans les
lycées le parti e élevé assemblé en
décalage même avec son propre électorat
alors qu'est-ce que vous dites vous ce
matin est-ce que l'été 2023 a été une
occasion manquée pour les écologistes
alors je vais pas vous dire qu'on se
serait pas passé de la polémique sur
Médine ce serait malhonnête et c'est pas
mon genre donc bien sûr qu'on s'en
serait passé maintenant
une fois que il était invité ça me
paraissait compliqué d'annuler
l'invitation il est venu il a dit des
choses par ailleurs assez assez forte
j'aimerais bien que d'autres personnes
suivent cet exemple de revenir d'essayer
de déconstruire ces erreurs puisqu'il y
en a qui sont évidentes il a eu des
affaires
comme ça
bref vous me permettez juste sur les
chiffres que vous montez on est en berne
ça marche pas etc moi je me suis pas
bonne moi je me souviens très bien la
dernière élection européenne en 2018 un
an avant on était à 3 4% dans les
sondages au niveau européen
on prévoyait il y avait des études
d'opinion qui démontraient que on
risquait de ne plus avoir de groupes
écologistes au Parlement européen
puisqu'on n'allait pas avoir assez
d'éluses assez de pays pour former un
groupe imaginez c'était la catastrophe
une première depuis la création du
groupe écologiste au Parlement européen
bon un an plus tard on a fini avec ce
qu'on a appelé la vague verte le plus
grand groupe écologiste au Parlement
européen qui avait jamais existé et dans
la suite les succès des municipal en
France en Allemagne plusieurs parties
écologistes qui rentrent au gouvernement
en Allemagne en Autriche enfin Landes au
Luxembourg en Irlande etc donc je vous
dis pas que c'est pas intéressant je
vous dis pas que je les regarde pas ces
sondages oui je dis juste que il vous
inquiétez pas du coup
franchement à un an des élections on ne
sait pas qui va aller voter ils disent
pas grand chose on est à 8%
10% parce que ça dépend il y a des
enquêtes entre 8 et 12 donc on est
autour de 10 la dernière fois on était à
4 bon écoutez c'est plutôt
de personnalité est-ce que là Marie
Toussaint il va pas y avoir un problème
d'incarnation elle est très très peu
connue des Français mais Yannick Jadot
était pas extrêmement connu avant de
faire la campagne des européennes Marie
tout ça elle va être connue pendant la
campagne la campagne n'a pas commencé
donc évidemment que avant la campagne on
n'est pas dans la même situation
qu'après entre maintenant et le 9 juin
2024 il va se passer quelque chose on va
faire campagne sur notre projet et Marie
Toussaint elle va porter nos
propositions des propositions très
fortes et c'est une candidate
extrêmement solide et je bien sûr que
aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans la
situation du 9 juin 2024 donc on verra
si vous voulez on en parle le 10 ce qui
reste c'est que vous avez aussi une
nouvelle secrétaire nationale depuis le
mois de décembre dernier marine
Tondelier ce qui interroge aussi c'est
peut-être sa stratégie politique selon
vous est-ce qu'elle est est-ce que c'est
la bonne
la stratégie politique c'est-à-dire du
choix de les thèmes que qui ont été
portés cet été est-ce que c'est ce sont
les bons non mais on va pas revenir
encore une fois
l'affaire de l'invitation de Médine aux
journées d'été personne n'aurait voulu
que ça se passe comme ça marine
Tondelier non plus et sur les abeilles
enfin le positionnement très à gauche de
LV est-ce que c'est la bonne stratégie
politique
le fait qu'il y ait comme vous dites un
décalage avec l'opinion pour moi ça
démontre plus l'impact qu'à ce débat et
qu'on les prises de position des
responsables politiques sur les femmes
musulmanes depuis des années sur
l'opinion publique c'est-à-dire que si
vous racontez tous les jours à la télé
tous les jours tous les jours on a un
problème avec le voile on a un problème
avec le voile on a un problème avec le
voile et les abeilles assez mal les
abeilles assez mal et oui il arrive un
moment ou même les électeurs écologistes
se disent ah bah oui il y a peut-être un
problème avec la Baya donc moi ce
sondage pour moi il démontre pas que on
a un problème nous il démonte que oui
quand on passe sa journée à expliquer un
problème avec les musulmans et à vouloir
contrôler la manière dont elle s'habille
et à vouloir les libérer à leur place et
savoir mieux qu'elle comment elles
doivent s'habiller pour être des femmes
libres et ben oui ça a un impact sur
l'opinion publique dans d'autres pays où
ce n'est pas un sujet vous faites le
même sondage personne vous dit on a un
problème avec les abaya même les gens
savent pas trop ce que c'est et pour les
européennes est-ce que vous validez
cette stratégie manuelle bon par le chef
de la France insoumise disait hier qu'il
croyait encore à une liste commune de la
gauche et qu'il fallait faire l'union
non les élections européennes ce sont
les seules élections en France les
seules élections où on a la
proportionnelle intégrale ce sont les
seules élections vraiment
représentatives on n'a pas besoin comme
pour les présidentielles de faire
d'alliance avant les élections on les
fait après une fois que les électeurs se
sont exprimés nous avons des projets qui
sont parfois complémentaires mais qui
sont différents les écologistes sont des
fédéralistes nous voulons plus
d'intégration européenne nous voulons un
plus grand budget nous voulons la fin
des véto-nationaux ce n'est pas la même
chose les gens décideront et après bien
sûr qu'on se parlera ce qui n'empêche
pas parce que c'est ça la petite musique
que moi personnellement je commence à
vraiment être fatigué de cela ça
n'empêche pas qu'en 207 nous devons
avoir et nous aurons j'en suis convaincu
une candidature commune de cet espace
politique puisque pour cette élection là
c'est nécessaire c'est ce qu'il faut
faire et nous sommes toutes et tous en
train de travailler au fait que ça
puisse arriver dans les meilleures
conditions et ce n'est pas la même
élection les élections européennes c'est
au sujet de l'Europe ce n'est pas le
premier tour l'avant-prem tour de 2027
c'est le seul tour de 2024 merci Mélanie
regel merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin merci Quentin